en las manos de esta profesora de
historia y geografía una carta con una
amenaza recibida después de que ella
sugirió a los alumnos participar en un
concurso nacional sobre la resistencia y
el holocausto recibió una carta anónima
diciendo que formaba parte de un grupo
de presión acusándome de ser peor de un
colaborador durante la segunda guerra
mundial
ella cree que las amenazas vinieron del
padre de uno de sus alumnos y a pesar
del apoyo de la dirección se sintió sola
mientras se enfrentaba a esta situación
la elección de las palabras realmente me
afectó presentó una queja a la policía
por supuesto pero no hubo ninguna
investigación y no son sólo las clases
de historia las que están bajo presión
los profesores de francés también están
recibiendo quejas a veces muy agresivas
no si fue me dijeron sobre los dioses
griegos no esto es falso sólo hay un
dios y que desde ese punto lo único que
importaba era lo que estaba escrito en
la biblia otro ejemplo es tres alumnos
se negaron a entrar en una iglesia
durante
excursión escolar así que esto ocurre
con todas las principales religiones
público monetarismo estos incidentes
están generando un debate entre alumnos
y maestros pero bcs el diálogo parece
imposible por ejemplo un alumno durante
un ejercicio de dictado prefirió perder
puntos en lugar de escribir el nombre de
dios porque el alumno era judío o bien
los niños me dicen estás hablando de la
deriva de los continentes pero no puedo
ser que hizo la tierra de estas
tensiones no siempre se señalan
oficialmente el año pasado sólo se
reportaron unos mil casos